[Music]
hello and
welcome to night city wire episode three
the show from us
at cd projekt red where we talk about
all things
cyberpunk 2077. in today's episode
we're going to start by taking you on a
tour of night city
in a new gameplay video and have a chat
with senior level designer miles
then we're going to introduce you to the
gangs of night city in
another new gameplay video and have a
chat with mataysh from our quest team
then before we finish today's episode
we're gonna give you a look at some of
the
incredible finalists in our pc case
modding contest
and we have some information that uh pc
players have been waiting to hear
so let's get started it's time to take
you on a tour of
night city
oh my god juanita here today's news is
novamax
hi there new tonight city
it's not so bad here how are we feeling
today
because i feel amazing
the food the tie on seventh and haywood
the pierogies down by the docks a home
of pride and as always your business
is my business and this is
endless possibilities and endless lies
we are [ __ ] america and i don't know
how we're going to fix it
the homeless population in night city
has risen by 300
[Music]
crime in night city is now double the
rate than in the new united states
on your own you're [ __ ]
well on that note that's it for today's
info flash sleep tight night city
the grass ain't greener anywhere else
night city what does it mean to you how
well do you know it's history
who was richard knight how many stations
are in the endcart system
which city district boasts the best
burrito in town
the answers to these questions and more
can be found at the address at the
bottom of your screen
check it out and fall in love with night
city all over again
[Music]
well since night city is one of our
stars of this episode
there is actually quite a lot to talk
about so let's start at the beginning
how did night city come to be because
yes it exists in the world of the
tabletop
but uh how do you take that and make
what we've got now
well yeah as you can imagine making a
city that is as big
and complex as night city is is
quite the ambitious project first off we
sat down and we're really considering
what is it that we wanted to do with
night city in a way
night city is the style of cyberpunk
right it is one of its
main characters we wanted to make a city
that is very very believable right i
mean the word immersion gets thrown
around a lot but really we wanted you to
be able to dive into it and feel like
this is a real place
and then secondly we also wanted to
provide enough variety between districts
so that exploring night city will always
be fun right there's no point in making
a city
that is all sameish and you know it
doesn't really matter where you go
because
once you've been through one district
you feel like you've been through all of
them so for that
we first of started taking a look at the
real life geography that night city is
located on and that would be
on the coast of california knowing that
night city would be
a coastal city gave us a bit of insight
into what we would
expect from the city layout you'd expect
the port
you'd expect huge industrial areas that
would facilitate this kind of trade that
you would assume a kind a city of this
type
would have with the world and then we
went through
and actually divided the city into
several districts
six of them and some of them are based
on the original
lore we decided to give their own
characteristics in terms of um
architecture their demographics the kind
of people that would live there
and also the function within the city
each of these districts in turn we
divide it into further sub-districts
which we further characterized using the
more grand
theme of the larger district this
process
i think has resulted in a city that is
feels quite alive has a lot of character
where each
district feels like its own distinct
zone without
feeling separated from the larger
picture and that results in something
that
allows the player to easily navigate
even the
complex concrete jungles of night city
simply by looking around and
always having a rough idea where you
actually are but night city is clearly
so different from anything we've ever
created with the witcher can you give us
some idea about
or some insight into just how big and
like how densely packed
night city really is yes um so
i'm not exaggerating when i'm saying
that night city is easily the most
complex thing
that i or the others have worked on the
city
is super organic right it's not like a
chessboard layout
but the the layout of the city is crazy
and you can tell that it
grew in phases right where buildings
have been built on top of each other
and i guess the mega buildings that we
have showcased are a great example of
this
um you'll actually see that they are
located on
some kind of pillar you know and then
expand outside and then up
up high into the sky and underneath it
you'll have space for other buildings
this yields a lot of interesting
experiences when it comes to exploration
and that's the one thing i'm most
excited about for players to experience
we've been saying that our exploration
is super vertical
right but what this really means is that
it changes the way you
explore the city compared to our
previous games
you won't be able to easily set out on a
target
in the distance right you won't be able
to say oh there's a castle on a hill
over there i'll try to get there and
then you'll be lost on the way
but here it's much more intimate much
more moment to moment you might be
roaming the cities and
get a call by your fixer who informs you
about a job nearby that you might be
able to do
right or you find an alleyway and you
walk down one of the many many alleyways
that the city has to offer and it's
always a surprise you don't know if you
might stumble upon
some gangers hanging out that are up to
no good sometimes
and these are the moments that i often
get surprised with you even stumble upon
the odd elevator that is meant to
connect parts of the
you know different layers of the city
and it's quite astonishing sometimes to
see
where you come out when you enter one of
these and you know find that oh this is
actually how it connects to the world
that's crazy and now i'm here
now i know there's a shortcut that i can
take
and again this all serves to
really enhance this sense of wonder that
we all come to love from open world
games and the whole city is built to
cater to that
i mean you guys have really brought
night city to life and i really want to
make a point of that it is a living
breathing
city so as a level designer can you give
us some insight into those little
touches that you guys have made because
i hear you guys have even been placing
rubbish by hand
oh yes um we've been placing quite a bit
of rubbish and that's certainly one of
the more glorious parts of being a level
designer or an environment artist where
you get to litter
the streets that you've spent time
building with the garbage but it's
details such as this that um we find
really
important to make the city feel alive
and also we take great pride in the
process of making this right
we have a lot of fun actually placing
all of what we call
mini stories right these are little
encounters
um that you can find when you simply
walk
along the streets of course we have huge
quests right
side quests we have lots of side
activities that you can do
but it always is nice to just kinda stop
down for a minute and take a look at
your surroundings and that we have so
lovingly created and try to see
if there maybe isn't something that you
can be a little detective for
now one other thing that i think is
really really cool is also the fact that
we have
actually named every single street in
the city so
not only will npcs be able to
communicate their locations or the
locations they want you to visit by sort
of referring to the street names
but also you will be able to talk to
your friends about it in that way right
have you been to
poplar street in japan town for example
um
and i think this is a small detail but
the philosophy that we have with these
kind of things
is that you know many many small things
contribute to the sum of it
which is hopefully then you being able
to explore a city that you feel is truly
alive
and that you haven't been experiencing
before
uh well miles thank you so much for
giving us your insight i suppose when
the game launches you could be an
official night city tour guide instead
right
i might be yeah you know if this game
death thing doesn't work out for me i
might
might retire and become a tour guide in
night city
don't forget that if you are tuning in
late or if you just
want to watch anything again we will be
uploading everything to our channels
soon now from the sixth street to the
valentinos it's time to introduce you to
the gangs of
night city
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know how things work in night city
stronger survive but that's how things
stand
you're either somebody where you fizzle
out into nothing
then see in a city that lets you get by
without buddies
be very careful my friend we are also
far from home
which gang's the city's biggest and
baddest according to the ncpd
scavs hold the body count title or
maelstrom
depending on the season one time a
maelstrom ganger killed a young kid
right in front of my eyes
for shits and giggles sucking psychos
and who the [ __ ] are you to say what can
and can't be i'm gonna introduce you to
our meat grinder
about time we had some fun big mess
you'll never forget
never i hate these pork [ __ ]
just a gang like any other right i'll
take the valentinos
they follow
how'd you meet jackie we started out
together in the valentinos
no in the [ __ ] bible book club i
gotta give style points to the
valentinos
they have a punishment for every
occasion
quick shout out to everyone in haywood
and santo domingo lately the valentino's
in sixth street have had a bigger bone
to pick
sixth street why'd they want to wipe you
i can't [ __ ]
stand tinos i've dealt with sick street
before
we do the run they'll transfer the cred
come on let's go before 6th street shows
up
shot shot shot any more second amendment
fans in the house huh
uh hate those bastards vomit lofty
patriotic [ __ ] all day
time to bring on the future any idea how
many attacks from behind the black wall
we neutralized
if the voodoo boys breach the black wall
we'll all be [ __ ]
voodoo boys urban myth i thought
just net runners spooking each other no
such gang you know i heard a few things
about you
voodoo boys best runners in town you do
not steal from the voodoo boys
i see you always for them pacifica is
just haiti 2.0 their own island cut off
from the rest of the city
this is our turf our home until last
week the animals crawled
animals are the craziest [ __ ] gang in
the city
[Music]
animals aren't the play here are they
they're hired muscles someone else
needed
i [ __ ] you over you [ __ ] the gang
over somewhere at the start of the story
somebody [ __ ] the court see how this
works now
[Music]
my husband's new westbrook very high in
the tiger class
they did what made the best eddies sword
sex and black market
see a lot of tigers they run this place
know what else they do well break the
needs of people who ask
the [ __ ] up the questions will kill us
come on baby
tiger claws killed one girl too many so
people took matters into their own hands
spoken ballistic girls pimps
outcast the whole freak show it's how
the mocs got started
us have each other's back we look out
for one another
you're looking for some company tonight
how'd you hook up with the mocks
i thought susie and the gang could
really change something in this city
moxes and nomads don't seem so different
both seem to yammer a lot about
community
solidarity tell me about the badlands
not much going on out here
oh contraire this is an ecosystem
nomads grafton shiv corporations and
drifters
they form a complete hole remove one
part
the delicate balance topples here in the
aldocaldos it all stays in the family
classic dilemma what comes first family
or the outside world
this family will go to hell and back
everyone in this city lives in their own
bubble
and either you fly high or sink into
quicksand
[Music]
matajus thank you so much for joining us
i have personally been really excited to
give people a closer look at the gangs
we've shown a little bit on twitter but
their styles are so distinct
yes i enjoyed them a lot as well in our
game i think they're very cool
but let's start them with the kind of
role that they play because gangs really
do play a prominent role in night city
correct
yes definitely the gangs they rule the
streets of night city you know they have
the newest cyberware they have the
newest weaponry
and they are really a power that
everyone needs to take into account when
they are
thinking of operating in night city you
will encounter them as you explore the
city of course but also as you complete
main quests side quests different jobs
for the for the fixers
sometimes you might even get hired by
them but then
i suppose everybody's thinking then can
you join a gang
well v is a merc and mercs of night city
are this
unique distinct group that stick mostly
to themselves right
and they get jobs from variety of
factions they can get jobs from
corporations they can get jobs from
gangs they can get job from
uh different kind of like influential
clients because of this
nobody will ever trust a merc to be one
of them
right and the gangs are no exception
here they are looking only for like
people that they know will be loyal to
them right and that they will
fight for their cause all of the time
not just some of the times when it's
profitable to them
so because of this we will mostly stick
to the afterlife and the after
our life are this group of mercs this
legendary group of mercenaries in night
city
they get the best jobs they get the most
money the best clients and so on so if
you want to become
a legend in night city you are going to
the afterlife
so we've obviously mentioned distinct
style then so does that mean there are
kind of special gang themed weapons and
items and clothing for players to
find and use yes definitely there are
different vehicles that you can drive
for example there are cars there are
motorbikes
then of course there are different
pieces of clothing
themed after gangs there are weapons and
so on so
yeah definitely there are things to look
forward to i suppose there's somebody
who's spent as much time as you have
kind of getting to know the gangs i have
to ask which is your favorite and why
so i would have to say probably
maelstrom
simply because they have this unique
distinct feel
uh and this weird aesthetic about them
so the idea about maelstrom is they are
people who want to cross
the boundary between the machine and
human right they are
changing so much of their body with
cyberware that they
no longer look human really on top of
that they are also very unpredictable
it's very difficult to say what they
will do
at any point when you meet them at one
moment they can be shaking hands with
you and at the other moment
you know they will pull gano again out
on you and they bring in this element of
chaos into the game which i
really enjoy personally oh matty thank
you so much for joining us it's always
interesting to learn what uh your
favorite gang is i think it kind of
tells me a little bit about you
oh does it what does it say about me
well we'll talk about that later but for
now before we wrap up today's episode
we asked people to show us their
creativity and design
a pc case mod cyberpunk style
our panel of judges selected five
finalists and we teamed them up with
professional case models
to bring their concept to reality
[Music]
these five amazing designs will be
fighting for the main prize an
alienware aurora pc along with other
awesome gaming peripherals
brought to you by our partners alienware
nvidia
and steelseries let's see the mods
and numbers i absolutely love this one
the whole aesthetic works with each
other
absolutely next level honestly kind of
terrifying
exactly the type of thing i would expect
to find at a trade show
it really looks like it could have come
straight out of the game
[Music]
[Music]
to watch the full pc case modding video
and to get more information about when
the winning design will be available on
charity auction stay tuned to our social
media channels
looking at those pc case mods it reminds
me that we do have
one more thing to reveal if you're going
to be playing cyberpunk 2077
on pc when it launches this november we
do have some specs to share that i think
some of you have been waiting for the
minimum system requirements for
cyberpunk are a windows 7 or 10 pc
an intel core i5 3570k
or amd fx8310 eight gigs of ram
and an nvidia geforce gtx 780
or an amd radeon rx470
in the storage department the game will
take up roughly 70 gigs of space
and although it will run off hdd we do
recommend an ssd
as for the recommended specs you're in
the green if you're rocking windows 10
an intel core i7 4790
or amd ryzen 3 3200g
12 gigs of ram and an nvidia geforce
gtx 1060 or amd radeon
r9 fury thank you so much for joining us
for episode 3 of night city wire
don't forget that if you've missed
anything or if you just want to watch
again
we will be uploading everything to our
channels shortly
and we will be back soon with episode 4.
you